what can i possibly say to the sun i
abandoned
you got big
happens
hey guys pete here this will be my
breakdown of dexter new blood episode 2.
we got some answers about where his son
harrison's been and how he showed up in
iron lake and a look at how much more
difficult it could turn out to be for
dexter if he decides to indulge his dark
passenger in this small town deck spends
most of the episode thinking about being
a dad deb objects to this but he can't
imagine letting go of harrison again now
that he's found him and we also meet the
father of his victim from episode one an
imposing character kurt caldwell who
doesn't yet know for sure that he's lost
his son we'll get into all of that after
a quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched episode 2 of dexter new blood
then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it in episode 1 there was a scene with a
young woman at the bar she seemed to be
just passing through she was from out of
town she was low on cash and angela
picked up on this and helped her out in
this week's episode we find her in a
hotel room or something similar she's
getting out of the shower and she's
having some champagne and there's a
camera in the room that someone's
watching when she wakes up she looks in
her bag and can't find her phone she's
surprised by this and then she looks at
the door and realizes that she can't get
out so she starts banging and screaming
for help then she notices the camera
which isn't hidden from her at all it's
right there where she can see it and
when she looks closer she notices that
someone wrote you're already dead where
they know that she would see it so she's
locked in someone's watching and it
looks like this is set up to be menacing
so that's happening in the background i
can't see how that won't be tied to the
missing girls in town and i'll come back
to discuss that later after we talk
about what else is happening the episode
proper opens with dexter and harrison
sitting across from each other at his
table it's a classic awkward dexter
situation where he can't figure out how
to act only here there are real stakes
as he's trying to put together what he
could possibly say to the son he's
abandoned it's difficult and he settles
on you got big and we get the idea that
harrison is pretty sharp after he turns
down the offer of blueberry pancakes he
throws it out there he says so you're
not dead and i think it's around here
where it becomes apparent that the
casting of jack alcott was a pretty good
find for the show they resemble each
other enough and he does a solid job of
interacting with michael c hall in this
exchange
in their talk we learned that hannah
died three years ago from pancreatic
cancer he tells him that growing up
without a dad that was hard but then
finding this letter after she died and
finding out that his father let him
believe he was dead for all those years
that was brutal through the return
address on that he found his way to the
town in oregon found out he left and
came across the name jim lindsey which
he says do you know how many of those
there are on the internet which was all
part of dexter's plan he ended up
finding him from a bowling photo on fred
jr's instagram where he was bragging
about jim lindsey rolling a 300 game he
wants to know what happened to dexter
morgan and all that his father can say
is it's not who i am anymore dexter had
to die and then he cuts things short
saying why don't you get some rest and
i'll tell you everything in the morning
making a promise deb appears when he
goes into the bathroom and it's almost
like a horror movie vibe she taps on the
window with the bullet she pulled out of
her stomach until it breaks and shouts
that he's not listening he thinks that
keeping harrison there will keep him
from killing again and that's something
he needs and she fires back that he's a
selfish psycho he's emotionally
handicapped and that if he does manage
not to kill him he's surely gonna [ __ ]
him up
later towards the end of the episode we
see another one-on-one with them where
dexter asks him if he wants to stay at
first harrison's not sure he didn't come
here for all of this he came for answers
and he wants to know why he left them
and he wants to know if it's because of
what he wrote in the letter where he
told hannah to reach out to him if
harrison showed any dark tendencies
unsurprisingly he wants to know what
that means and what was so wrong with
him that he not only left but he faked
his own death to hide there's probably
no version of the story where he comes
to the conclusion that it would be best
to tell him the truth about a serial
killing so he just says it wasn't you he
explains that he's always had his demons
he does look like he at least thinks
about telling him what's really going on
but then just moves on to i was scared i
would pass that on i would mess you up
so i went away because of what i am not
what you are and explains that he was in
a dark place after he lost rita his mom
and then after that aunt deb so he
thought he would thrive with hannah that
walking away from him was the hardest
thing he's ever done and now he regrets
it because he never imagined that he'd
be left alone
when dex offers maybe he can be there
for him now harrison says stop acting
like you're an evil person the worst
thing you ever did was leave me and he
probably thinks that's true and in the
end he says that he'll stay for a while
so to rewind a little bit and talk about
the plot dexter wakes up after the crazy
night when he goes outside he notices
that there's blood from matt next to his
cabin he thinks to himself this is what
happens when i give in to my dark
passenger but i can fix this and this
feels like the old dexter's way of
thinking not the guy that we watched for
the first episode and as he's busy
covering it up a group of police cars
pull up on his property angela explains
that the cops are there because matt
caldwell disappeared in the woods near
there and because his place is close to
all the public hunting grounds they
wanted to set up their base camp for
their search there after he agrees she
says she wants to go inside and she
meets harrison who reveals that he's
dexter's son which is a pretty big
surprise for his girlfriend and we see a
little smile on dex's face while he's
watching inside she finds out that his
mother died that's why he came there and
he thinks quick enough to refer to his
father as jim and he explains later that
he didn't do that to protect him but
that he just didn't want to cop up all
in his business which is the first time
that we start to wonder if he's just
like his dad or not as the searchers
head out angela mentions that they left
the seneca land and then dexter
remembers the blood trail so he
volunteers to go that way with harrison
he tries to cover up the blood trail as
they're driving in his atv harrison asks
about angela we find out that he's only
been in iron lake for a couple of years
and the whole thing with angela is
recent he doesn't have a great
explanation for why he chose there but
he thinks to himself that there's no
temptations from the outside world they
do find the deer and that gives him a
chance to send harrison back to get the
others while he's trying to figure out
where he went wrong deb shows up to
laugh at him as he finds the rock where
matt hit his head and cleans it with
windex before throwing it into the woods
then he goes to plant matt's glove by
the highway and while he's doing that
some of the seneca people show up and he
gets the chance to plant the seed that
maybe matt killed the deer when the
others arrived the seneca elder mentions
that the police and the whole town are
out looking now that a caldwell kid went
missing when one of their girls
disappears they get the story that
runaways usually come back he brings up
the name of iris and it sounds like
angela lost a daughter of her own at
some point in the past and she says that
things are different in iron lake now
while they're taping off the crime scene
and getting ready to bring the deer back
fred jr finds the glove and the idea
develops that after matt killed the deer
he got scared and ran seeing that the
cops are somewhat incompetent except for
angela harrison questions dexter why he
isn't working as a policeman anymore and
he doesn't get too far into it beyond
saying that he wasn't actually a cop he
just worked for the police
back at the cabin dexter notices that
harrison is good with animals and he
tells him that he has to leave but if he
wants to he can just wait inside because
he knows it's awkward meeting new people
to a surprise he realizes that harrison
isn't socially awkward at all he meets
audrey and she asked him to join them on
the search introducing him to zach and
scott after they recovered the bullet
angela says they need to talk she isn't
put off about the harrison situation
like dexter expected she can respect
that he's been secretive about his past
saying that they all have secrets and
she throws it out there that she's not
audrey's birth mother she tells him that
he could have told her about his secret
and now that it's out there maybe they
can start talking about parenting the
pressures the worry the guilt he admits
that he doesn't know if he can be the
father that harrison needs and she tells
him all he basically has to do is just
show up all the teenagers make their way
to a camp when the other kids can't open
the door harrison steps up to use his
pocket knife and get inside and then the
kids start to get high and harrison
declines their offer saying that he has
a history with drugs but got clean a few
years ago things get awkward when they
ask about his mom and his stepmom dying
he had offered that his stepmom had died
of cancer and they wanted to know how
rita died he decides to leave to get
some wood for the fire and while he's
gone they start looking through his bag
they find a sketchbook apparently he can
draw and on his way back in he sees them
and makes a noise so that they'll know
he's coming that night dexter's thinking
about how he got out of this he hid the
blood left the glove matched the bullet
to matt's gun and he did all of that
just to get rid of these people angela
arrives shortly after and says that
they're calling off the search because
the glove was a match and the narrative
that dexter threw out there is working
at least for the time being when the
kids come back from the camp audrey and
angela get into an argument and here we
hear that name iris again she says she's
being overprotective and how many times
do i have to tell you that i'm not iris
after things calm down it looks like
everything's going pretty well right up
until the moment when kirk caldwell
shows up he doesn't believe the story he
says matt would have called him if he
was in trouble he always does and that a
poaching fine wouldn't be enough to
scare him away he's not perfect and he's
made mistakes in his life but he doesn't
deserve to freeze out there in the woods
and he thinks that's what's going to
happen angela tries to get him inside so
they can talk but instead he just turns
and addresses everyone there asking for
help saying i need you to stand up for
me like i stood up for you and he talks
about all the things his family does for
the community and that this is iron lake
where we all look out for each other
that's enough to get them going again
and they'll be out there throughout the
night he notices harrison and introduces
himself as he's saying that matt's out
there and i'm gonna find him if it's the
last thing i do then the camera drops
down through the fire and we see the
bags holding his remains and his gun as
the episode comes to an end
so it's fun to watch dexter have to
scramble to cover his tracks and we're
getting an idea of where things are
going in the bigger picture with the
girls going missing the details of
what's happening with the girl from the
bar weren't entirely clear for me how
she went from there and ended up trapped
inside the room but it seems evident
that someone's getting off on her being
there and her being terrified we only
get a look at an eye but it pretty much
looks like kirk caldwell's to me and
there's also the hint that they weren't
able to reach him for hours at that same
time they're also doing some work to
make the billionaire come off as
suspicious and it's at least possible
that we're supposed to suspect him or
that either dexter or the police will
suspect him there is a possibility that
he could turn out to be connected but
from what i gathered from the first
episode the girls have been going
missing for a long time and ed olsen was
just arriving in town angela went to his
estate earlier in the episode looking
for help with the search he didn't
hesitate to offer his helicopter but
then he did ask about her daughter
audrey saying that young people see
things in binary terms black and white
good and evil the oil baron persona it
ignores all the good that he does and he
makes a specific reference to donating
to the seneca people i hope there's more
than just resentment under the surface
with harrison he is just a kid but he's
not dumb so there should be some
suspicion as to why in the hell his
father faked his death beyond the
surface stuff dex is feeding him based
on the circumstances i think dexter
handled it pretty well but there should
be a nagging mistrust of this person who
harrison is invested in having a
relationship with also it seems like a
bad idea for him to be carrying the
letter from hannah with him around in
his backpack it makes for an interesting
dynamic that both dexter and harrison
are complete mysteries to each other
there's a building conflict with the
abandonment and now they both have to
trust that the other one is telling them
the truth about themselves it's also a
complicated dynamic with debes
conscience harrison is sympathetic
because he's had a messed up life and
dexter was directly responsible for all
of that remember that was the whole
thing in season four dex could have just
killed trinity right away but he wanted
to learn from him how he balanced his
family life with his killing that got
harrison's mom killed and then he
decided to send him to argentina with
hannah because he thought that would be
better but there's no way to get any of
that across without exposing what he
really is the thing is though the
pressure from deb is coming from that
same place his inclination to run away
because he wasn't sure if he could
actually change and make things safe by
himself he was able to keep that up
right up until the point when harrison
came back so you heard him mention that
he wanted to keep him there because it
would help him to keep from killing
again it's kind of the wrong way to look
at it and we'll see how that develops
over the rest of the season debra as
dexter's conscience isn't as fun of a
character as she could be when she was
alive in the earlier seasons but she's
not wrong about him either so it is
enjoyable to watch her mess with him
right now it's coming from his twisted
way of looking at things and through the
deb filter but maybe once the other
killer gets on his radar will get some
of the detective side of her rather than
just trying to keep him from making a
mistake with his son she is a person
that understands how costly those
mistakes can be they're definitely
playing with the idea of dexter trying
to find clues that might point towards
harrison having a dark passenger of his
own it seems like he might see that
darkness as his addiction he may be
looking to see if they have that in
common and he's looking for a way to
connect there when they brought it up it
seems like that's going to be a big part
of his backstory and i guess on some
level dexter would be able to understand
the compulsion there so they both have
secrets but they're not exactly on the
same level and angela has a secret a
missing daughter or maybe a sister i
suppose considering that audrey's birth
mom disappeared it seems pretty likely
that she could be a victim of this
killer but that's all a bit confusing
considering angela just wrote the mother
off without suspicion maybe it was one
of the first cases but even there you
think that she would connect the dots
there are quite a few things to think
about and i think that's a good place to
leave things let me know what stood out
to you in the comments and what you
thought of the episode please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon